Salut la team mentalo !
C'est le jour des explications... Je me suis pas rapproché un peu trop prés de la caméra là ?
C'est pas grave ! Je continue quand même !
C'est le jour des explications, donc je vous explique quelque chose pour bluffer les gens.
Mais un petit peu différemment, parce qu'on ne va pas parler ni d'un tour de mentalisme, ni d'une expérience, ni d'un tour de magie,
mais quelque chose d'usable et applicable au quotidien, via la suggestion.
La semaine dernière je vous ai parlé gentiment d'hypnose. C'était vraiment très très survolé.
Aujourd'hui c'est pareil, c'est encore un survol sur la suggestion.
Vous allez pouvoir faire une action dans le quotidien, qui va compétement bluffer les gens.
Vous allez agir sur des petits problèmes physiques très légers et votre suggestion dans la plupart des cas va déclencher un effet placébo chez la personne.
Deux explications pour le prix d'une. Donc aujourd'hui première explication:
Si quelqu'un a mal à la tête, quelqu'un souffre de douleurs à la tête, il ne faut pas que ce soit trop violent, on parle bien de petits mots de tête,
vous allez lui proposer de les faire passer.
Le vrai secret pour ça c'est que vous devez être autoritaire.
Pas autoritaire dans le sens où il faut lui crier dessus. Ça ne sert à rien d'hurler...
"Arrête ça tout de suite maintenant !"
Non, autoritaire dans le sens, où il faut faire preuve de compétences, vous savez ce que vous faites.
A aucun moment vous ne devez être dans l'hésitation, où faire semblant d'hésiter sur quelque chose.
Vous devez être franc, déterminé, directif, vif.
Vous expliquez à la personne que vous savez comment on fait passer les mots de tête, pour ça il n'y a pas de souci,
vous savez très bien faire, on vous la appris il y a quelques années, c'est efficace à 100%.
Vous passez derrière lui, et vous appuyez fermement, avec deux doigts sur les tempes.
Comme ceci.
Et avec vos pouces qui vous reste... parce qu'en temps normal vous êtes évidemment équipé d'une paire de pouces, c'est très pratique.
Vous les placez ici.
C'est-à-dire à la jonction entre la mâchoire et le cou.
Essayez de vous le faire sur vous même. Vous allez trouvez un endroit où, quand on appuie fermement, ça fait une sensation un peu inhabituelle.
En tout cas ça appuie un peu sur le muscle du cou et en même temps ça repose sur la mâchoire.
C'est pas un point que l'on a l'habitude de ressentir.
Donc vous passez derrière la personne, vous mettez les doigts là, les pouces derrière, et vous appuyez fermement pendant 1 minute.
Pendant cette minute là, vous lui parlez en lui demandant d'expirer très fort, cinq fois d'affilée, dix fois...
Et de se détendre au maximum, de se décontracter.
Tenez comme ça durant une minute, une minute trente.
Et avant de relâcher tout ça, expliquez que lorsque vous aurez terminé, la personne n'aura plus mal à la tête.
Ce sont des points très efficaces pour calmer le sang qu'il y a dans l'irrigation de la tête.
Inventez !
Inventez ! Mais soyez déterminé quand vous inventez.
Soyez autoritaire comme si vous saviez exactement ce que vous faisiez.
La personne ne doit pas avoir de doute sur l'efficacité de ce que vous faites.
Et quand vous aurez terminé, vous allez voir que la personne n'aura plus mal à la tête.
Ces simples suggestions associées à un contact physique, déclenche un léger effet placébo.
Qui fait que la personne va s'auto guérir sur son mal de tête.
On sait à quel point le cerveau peut influer sur le corps. A l'inverse il y a même des personnes qui somatisent.
Et bien là c'est la version positive. Vous pouvez aussi l'appliquer à quelqu'un qui a le hoquet.
Je vous explique comment faire si quelqu'un a le hoquet.
J'explique à la personne que je sais très bien faire passer le hoquet, que j'ai une technique infaillible pour ça,
mais c'est pas une technique genre banale... non c'est vraiment quelque chose d'efficace, qui marche très très bien.
Je prends sa main et j'appuie sur un point de shiatsu. C'est vrai, il s'agit d'un point de shiatsu, qui est juste ici, en médecine asiatique.
Mais c'est pour la constipation, donc rien à voir... mais la personne ne le sait pas.
J'appuie ici parce que ça fait une sensation un petit peu étrange, et je masse ici entre le pouce et l'index.
Et tout en massant, je ne regarde plus la personne, je regarde juste ce point là.
Et je fais des trucs bizarres, en étant concentré et en comptant.
Je fais:
J'appuie...
Et hop je masse un petit peu...
Je rappuie.
Je compte jusqu'à 4. Je masse un peu. Je rappuie, je compte jusqu'à 3, je masse un peu, etc. , jusqu'à 0.
Juste avant de commencer je demande à la personne de focaliser son regard sur ce point là, et en même temps mentalement
d'imaginer que son hoquet a disparu.
J'ai pas de statistique mais je pense qu'il a y environ 9 réussites sur 10.
Après, une fois que le hoquet a disparu vous pouvez vous amuser à expliquer que ce n'était pas vrai, et que vous avez utilisé une suggestion
pour déclencher un effet placébo.
Vous pouvez lui expliquer comment vous avez fait. Et lui faire partager aussi ce savoir là pour qu'elle puisse le faire à d'autres personnes.
Mais dans l'instant il est important qu'elle soit convaincue que vous ayez la connaissance et la compétence de faire ça.
J'espère que cette double explication d'aujourd'hui vous a plu. Je l'ai mis dans l'explication du dimanche parce que quand vous allez le faire à quelqu'un
vous allez voir que c'est bluffant.
Aussi bien pour la personne que pour vous.
C'est également une autre manière d'aborder le mentalisme.
Si cela vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit généreux et gracieux...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'hésitez pas à mettre un commentaire en bas de la vidéo, vous savez que je les lis, je sais que vous savez, vous savez je sais que vous savez.
Passez un excellent dimanche, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner en cliquant ici ou en dessous avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H, parce que le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Ciao !